does Mike Pereira fill out a college
basketball bracket that's what a lot of
people here at the Rich Eisen show want
to know so I present the question to you
Mike do you actually fill out a bracket
for the NCAA tournament or you've got
other things to do I haven't missed one
yet perfect the bracket is still perfect
are you are you really pulling my chain
now you really got a perfect bracket no
that means I didn't even fill one out I
mean I'm like stuck with you know I'm
watching games of the Alliance of
American football I'm doing all this
stuff and I just I just never really got
in the basketball this year okay because
a lot of people over the last couple of
days are trying to figure out why is
gene starett or talking about basketball
rules Mike is like hey isn't that the
former NFL referee but people don't
understand that a lot of NFL referees
and College referees don't just or
officials don't just do football they
also do basketball as well yeah we have
had we've had others of course Bill
vinovich still does it worked in college
basketball Tom Lincoln was a great
downfield official that we had in our
league and he had made it all the way to
the Final Four in basketball officiating
too you know most of most of the
officials that that go at all beyond
high school or junkies of some sort or
another and so you you have worked you
have worked different sports you know I
worked basketball when I was younger on
the high school level and so you look at
a person Heights territory which is why
I thought that was a perfect choice that
he was a perfect choice for CBS because
I knew he could give some real clutch
insight into basketball in the
tournament and there's just so many
games and so many plays that come up and
when I listened yesterday to a few games
and watched him and saw gene come on he
was like spot-on on the plays with
flagrant ones and all this kind of stuff
and and he to me he did a great job in
football in his first year and I think
he's doing a
really great job in basketball so far in
the tournament you know Mike you
mentioned it it's he's you know big on
all the rules whether it's the college
basketball or the NFL rules but for you
Mike I got a chance to see you a couple
weeks ago down on the sideline at an AAF
game down in San Diego and I'm watching
you as you're kind of looking at this
game and what's going on with sort of
the rules for the AAF and possibly
implementing them in the NFL now before
I get to the NFL rules proposals what
have you seen so far with the way that
the AAF game is working that can
probably be implemented in the NFL well
I'll tell you nobody seems to be missing
the kickoff you know that has become you
know a play in the NFL that that that
you know in terms of the touchback it's
there's so few returns and and I was
interested to see how that was going to
look like you know once we you know did
it in the AAF the Alliance and and quite
frankly I think it was accepted right
from the get-go and I think it's
interesting that the you know that the
NFL actually has a proposal on the table
that talks about you know the what we
call just a conversion and on-site
conversion in the Alliance and and the
NFL's talking about a play that starts
fourth and 15 and I forget from the 35
or something like that
yeah and and seems to have the backing
of the competition committee so it's not
gonna limit the kickoff necessarily but
it is going to be a different way to
attempt and probably a safer way to you
know attempt to keep the ball as you
would in an onside kick so you know that
has been good I mean the addition of the
sky judge to me has been good um hasn't
been used very much because of the fact
that we haven't had a lot of pass
interference plays which the sky judge
can review inside of five minutes of the
fourth quarter and not too many players
safety plays that have come up or the
side judge the sky judge could have
gotten involved in but it's that safe
that the Alliance has successfully used
that I really think is something that
needs to be looked at you know not just
in the NFL but I think in the NCAA level
also Mike Pereira the Fox NFL college
football officiating analyst joining the
Rich Eisen show Kirk Morrison filling in
for Rich now we know next week is the
NFL League meetings and a lot of these
proposals will be on the table of the
major rule of changes which really
involved like you mentioned replay and
and possibly you know overtime rules if
there was one that you think really has
a strong chance of being approved by the
owners which rule do you think will
probably pass next week well I think
there's a couple I mean the the ones
that you know that I like the most is
for some reason you know we have a rule
and the inability of a personal foul or
an unsportsmanlike conduct foul during a
scoring play or after a scoring play
there is no option to enforce that
penalty on the try and I get that when
the try was always from the two yard
line whether you attempted a two-point
try or one-point try but I made the
point that they needed to give the
offended team the option if it was
against the offense to put it on the
kick try because you'd obviously go
instead of you know snapping from the 15
you March it back 15 and snap from the
30 and last be looking at like a 47-yard
attempt so it really has an impact there
where it has so little impact if you
just roll it over onto the kickoff and
and I think that that clearly will pass
I mean there are a couple other little
penalty enforcement issues that you know
that nobody really cares the Hausa knows
about you know where do you where you're
gonna force a penalty when you have
fouls on both teams that occur after a
change of possession I mean those things
to me are clean ups you know the big
thing is what's happening in replay and
the proposals two of them in the
proposals that are going to allow
read play to get involved in pass
interference but I think they fall short
and I think the committee probably knows
they fall short because while they have
well I propose that replay can get
involved in pass interference anytime
during the course of the game and also
player safety roughing the quarterback
or illegal use of the helmet anytime
during court the course of the game it's
only when the penalty is called and so
it doesn't really correct the big issues
from last year certainly it doesn't have
doesn't do anything to change the
outcome of the championship game on the
pass interference in New Orleans that
was not called the hit by on Alvin
Camaro which was a vicious
helmet-to-helmet hit it wasn't called so
replay couldn't get involved in that so
I look at that and say both proposals
fall short I think that when the owners
get together and see that it doesn't do
anything to remedy the big situations
that came up last season I don't think
it'll pass I think it'll get tabled and
probably tabled until the main meeting
and maybe in the main meeting they can
come up with something that is maybe
more like what the Alliance does and
having that eighth official essentially
and he is an official and one of the
crew members and if he can make a change
in real time on a pass interference or a
personal foul situation if he can do it
within the time frame before the ball is
next snap do it get it done move on and
so maybe that will get discussed and in
them in the May meeting but I know that
Roger Goodell wants something done and
so when Roger wants something done
usually something's going to get done
but I just think what they have on the
you know on their plate right now in
terms of proposals Falls do short be Fox
NFL a fishing and officiating analysts
for college football and in a
my prayer we're joining the Rich Eisen
show you can follow him at on Twitter at
Mike Pereira and and Mike obviously it's
always the bigger games right in terms
of Super Bowl Conference championships
where plays happen or situations happen
and what do we do we rush to we need to
change the rule change the rule and I
say that because at the 8th and the AFC
championship game the Patriots won the
toss they went down they scored a
touchdown in overtime and the game was
over
now with the Chiefs proposing the rule
that both teams should be allowed at
least one possession is that something
that you can see being changed I look at
it as this way Mike you've already
changed the minutes from 15 to 10 and in
overtime and now you want to go with a
possession by possession is that
something more than it needs to be
collectively bargain because we talked
about player safety or could this one
just be changed because of the situation
that we saw in the conference
championship not having Patrick mahomes
I have an opportunity to beat this guy
the New England Patriots well I mean I
think it could be changed but for all
those reasons that you decided I doubt
that it will look at it like was almost
impossible to go from basically
sudden-death which was the way it was
originally to kick a long vehicle when
the game right it was pulling teeth just
to get the team's and the owners to
agree to basically go a two-possession
game as long as the first possession
didn't end in a touchdown or a safety I
doubt that there would be enough support
to you know to make this even longer and
and to guarantee two possessions and you
know the number of plays will increase
in its absolutely contrary to shorting
the time shortening the time from 15 to
10 but you know I'm of the opinion that
you know the team needs to play defense
and if you play defense and you succeed
in defense guess what you then get the
advantage if you if you are able to hold
the team to a field goal or less on your
on your on that first possession then
you create the advantage for yourself
knowing what you have
due to either tie or win so I just I
just don't see the change coming I get
it everything's about offense and
everything's about Patrick mahomes yeah
I get it all but to me I never see the
NFL parting ways with the term sudden
death they want it to be sudden death
and so you have that element now whereas
if you score the touchdown or create the
safety in that first series it is sudden
death and so I just don't see them going
away from that I got your Mike always
how's the golf game by the way
well kind of non-existent even though
we're near because of the weather up
here in Northern California and I am
going to go into the AAF game and the
Alliance game in San Antonio Saturday
and then I'm going to cruise in San
Antonio over to the Palm Desert and play
a couple of rounds so I'll report in but
I'm looking at my handicap going on the
rise after playing a couple rounds in
Palm Springs because I just am too rusty
I think I'm probably getting too old
that I just don't hit the ball as far as
anymore but are we happy to play if you
want to can't give up all my money that
that's too easy for you my huge so you
destroy me always Mike I appreciate the
time man and have fun when you do hit
the links all right I will do that I
promise you and I'll keep watching the
the Instagram aizen's Instagram he's
going to come back 300 pounds because
pre she ate the time Mike have a good
mess Mike career of the Fox NFL and
college football officiating analyst
join the Rich Eisen show the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience